consolation de ceux qui rentrent de
vacances les nouveaux modèles
automobiles de l'année qui vient citroën
ouvre le feu avec ses modèles qui
extérieurement ne se différencie pas des
précédents pourtant sous chacun de ces
capots il y à un nouveau moteur
il existe en effet désormais deux
déesses l'a19 et la 21
le moteur de la première développant 90
chevaux vitesse de pointe de 160 5
kilomètres heure celui de la seconde
développant 109 chevaux vitesse de
pointe de 175 kilomètres/heure il est 19
hérite de l'ancien moteur ds19 modifié
développement 80 chf au 158 km heure de
vitesse de pointe
cela a conduit à des modifications c'est
ainsi qu'une transmission nouvelle été
mise en place les freins à disques sont
pas de jeu de garnitures séparer
l'essieu avant et les amortisseurs ont
été modifiés le correcteur de rien en
voyage a été améliorée la déesse de 21
possède un dispositif de sécurité
adaptant automatiquement la direction
des phares à l'assiette de la voiture un
voyant d'indication du jour des
garnitures de freins les pneus sont
conçus pour une utilisation prolongée à
vitesse élevée
à l'autre extrémité de la production
citroën la deux chevaux subi des
modifications également glace de custode
arrière c'est-à-dire une troisième vitre
amortisseurs hydrauliques transmission
mot cinétique par jean un double
nouvelle calandre nouveau pare-chocs
l'ami 6 berline ou break ne connaît
aucune modification
tandis qu pour les modèles par à ceux
déjà connus
s'ajoute la 24 béat ou modèle simplifié
tels sont parmi d'autres les nouveautés
que 1966 vous offre
vous allez faire connaissance avec une
nouvelle voiture tout terrain
diane 6 méhari de citroën
sa carrosserie en plastique et
thermoformé teinté dans la masse
matériau miracle élastique et résistant
le moteur 3 chevaux 6 102 centimètres
cubes refroidissement à air puissance 33
chevaux
la vienne 6 méhari c'est un petit
véhicule économique qui s'adapte à
toutes les situations et peut
transporter 400 kg
notre cameraman roland gotha a pris le
volant pour apprécier la maniabilité de
la voiture
la légèreté du plastique fait que la
voiture ne pèse que 525 kg et la
suspension permet une adhérence et une
tenue de route remarquable exemple ce
ses prises de vue réalisées à bord de la
voiture par notre autre cameraman paul
fougerolles et ce nouveau véhicule peut
contenter une gamme importante d'usagé
entreprises de travaux publics
agriculteurs hôtelier marieur service de
surveillance artisans maraîchers
chasseurs pêcheurs touristes j'en passe
et j'en oublie
hier boulevard de brosses à dijon la
renault 12 a fait l'objet d'une
présentation remarquable et remarques
dernières nées d'une série déjà riche la
r12 vient en somme harmonieusement
compléter la gamme renault
c'est ce que devait notamment déclarer
lors de cette présentation
monsieur turbo directeur régional de la
régie à la nombreuse assistance dans
laquelle on reconnaissait monsieur
peltre est adjoint au maire le colonel
morel commandant la gendarmerie de
bourgogne que l'anem commandant le
septième roman crs est notre directeur
régional de la rtf monsieur pascal
copeaux auparavant sur les routes
ensoleillées de côte-d'or la r12 devait
faire ses preuves pour nous pour vous de
conception moderne
elle offre un aspect extérieur agréable
avec une ligne sobre légère tout en
nuances
notons au passage le capot long et
plongeant ainsi que le pare brise avant
qui permet une visibilité quasi totale
maniable rapide 140 km heure sa tenue de
route est excellent sur le plan
technique la r12 possède des
caractéristiques qui la place au
meilleur niveau par rapport à ses
rivales
c'est une berline 4 5 places 4 ports
traction avant doté d'un moteur à quatre
cylindres verticaux en ligne de 1300
centimètres cube pour une puissance
maximum de 60 chevaux à 5250 tours
minute
tout cela est complété par un système de
freinage qui offre garantit toute
garantie freins à disques sur les roues
avant à tambour sur les roues arrière le
résultat obtenu est excellent voyez vous
sous le capot là encore présentation
soignée
le coffre arrière quant à lui est large
et pas conséquent riche en possibilités
dernier point l'intérieur de la r12 les
banquettes sont munis de deux accoudoirs
centraux amovible et le tableau de bord
est à la fois rationnelle et esthétique
la r12 telle qu'elle se présente ainsi
et séduisant elle doit constituer dans
un avenir proche une chance
supplémentaire de réussite
internationale pour l'industrie
automobile française
24 comme 24 heures du mans sous ce
chiffre par vient de dévoiler à la
presse ses nouveaux modèles 24 ses
coaches et 24 s'était coupé qui continue
la série des 17
un système de réglage du volant et des
sièges avant qui permet de réaliser un
poste de pilotage sur mesure s'ajoute
aux qualités traditionnelles de la
panhard confort freinage économie est
très grande visibilité
la route secours trouvent place sous le
coffre arrière dans un logement spéciale
rendez vous au prochain salon